welcome to think fast talk smart a
podcast designed to hone your
communication skills my name is matt
abrahams i'm a lecturer here at
stanford's graduate school of business
where i teach strategic communication
and i'll be inviting my colleagues and
experts in to talk about best practices
you can use to become a more confident
authentic and compelling communicator
when we think about our communication at
work we tend to focus on our
presentations and meeting contributions
that we know we should spend time
preparing and practicing for
but if you think about it most of our
professional communication is
spontaneous in nature it's providing
feedback in the moment answering
questions introducing people
these spur of the moment communication
events can be as important if not even
more important than our planned high
stakes communications
for most people these impromptu
situations are quite challenging
i am thrilled to invite two experts and
good friends here today to talk about
how we can become more comfortable and
confident in these spur-of-the-moment
situations
let me start by introducing adam tobin
adam's a senior lecturer in film and
media studies here at stanford
university and he's a teacher in
continuing studies
dan klein is also a lecturer at stanford
both at the graduate school of business
as well as theater and performance
studies and dan also is an instructor at
the d school
adam and dan thanks for being here
thank you thank you glad to be here we
all are involved with
situations where the students we teach
or the clients we coach
feel challenged by spontaneous speaking
can you share a little bit about where
you think that challenge comes from why
is this type of speaking so hard
there's a moment when we feel that the
pressure is on it's like everyone's
attention is on us and we have to
perform and the moment we have that
self-conscious awareness it's like our
brain starts to short circuit we we go
into a different set of systems we're
thinking about ourselves we're thinking
about how it looks how we did
sometimes we see this in in with
improvisers specifically there's another
problem where if if the pressure's on
and you think you did really well
that also short-circuits your ability to
be present and in the moment and it's
amazing people can shut down
or sometimes people can talk too much
yeah where they can get you know their
voice can get higher low it's like their
mind body is
running away from them it's doing
everything except kind of what they need
to do in the moment but
we are
expert at that because for most of the
time we're improvising you know nobody
wakes up and writes the script of the
day and everyone else goes along with
that script we're actually experts at
improvising it's just when we get put on
the spot
and when adam says we are experts he
doesn't mean
me and adam he means like humanity we
are experts like huma we are excited
that's true you are that's why you're
here i just want to make sure everyone
we all are and we see this in in in lots
of high-stakes situations i think of
athletes who who for years have been
practicing what they do but in that
high-stakes situation that pitch that
putt where all the sudden they they fail
or they struggle because of that
over-awareness that that you're talking
about
you know before we start getting into
specific tips and and tricks about how
to manage in these situations i really
think a lot of what you guys teach has
to do with mindset and approach
would you guys like to talk about that
that approach that you take one of my
favorite stories is that
when i first moved to the bay area
before gps that's how ancient it was
i would go to san francisco and every
time i would get lost every single time
and it wasn't until the seventh or
eighth time that i got lost and i looked
up and i said i don't know where i am
but i've been lost here before
and if i just make a right and a right
i'll get back on the freeway and i know
how to get home and for me that was a
mindset shift that was i don't need to
have all the answers i need to be
present enough to kind of find a way to
solve the answers you know i need to be
okay enough
comfortable enough being uncomfortable
that i can plug in
and our mentor patricia ryan madsen who
wrote this great book improv wisdom when
i told her that story she said no no the
you've missed the point the point is to
get lost on purpose and discover what
you find
and for me that was another mindset
shift i love that i've been trying to
run a little bit more in my life this is
i probably started running after gps so
um and i find that it's really exciting
to go out and try to get a little bit
lost right i was running near my house
the other day in oakland and i i was
gonna go the way i know to get home and
i thought well i'll just i'll just get a
little bit lost and i turned right and
literally half a block they made a
native plants park in between two
streets it was 10 yards away from where
i was and i had a walk in nature
completely transported and i would have
never had that if my mindset wasn't get
a little bit lost like take the slightly
less traveled path
and in speaking if you're present if you
go just a little bit someplace you
hadn't gone before it may feel
terrifying at first but you're only
going to discover new things that way
that that i think is really the crux of
of what hinders a lot of people in these
situations is is that ability to let go
there is such pressure to do it right
the expectation is that i've got i've
been asked to do this or i need to do
this and i want to do it right and i
know in your experience and in a lot of
the improvisation that you bring to the
work you do
letting go of the getting it right is
really important so can you share some
ideas about how we get out of our own
way there's a wonderful saying that
comes from the world of improv and i'd
love to hear your thoughts on this but
this notion of dare to be dull
and when i i have the audacity to be in
front of my mba students and say dare to
be dull and it sucks the air right out
of the room because i immediately have
to follow it up with why and and and
would one of you like to help articulate
why daring to be dull is so liberating
it's exactly that it's liberating
because it takes the pressure off we are
so
driven to be interesting our mentor
patricia ryan madsen she had a mentor
and improvisation is keith johnstone so
he's like our grand mentor
and he great to meet
he said these like our fear of being
seen as unoriginal is one of the most
inhibiting fears that we carry and so
the idea of like dare to be dull or be
obvious be obvious is the most powerful
creative mantra that there is he said
when you're trying to be original you
sound like everyone else trying to be
original but when you're obvious you're
yourself and that's what's genuine and
if the obvious thing you say is what
everyone else was thinking then they'll
just think you're brilliant for saying
it and if your obvious thing is
different then that's actually genuinely
original
right
right and that obvious thing is is kind
of your voice right um but it's also
it's also true you're not putting on any
kind of
fake
version of yourself to try to impress
people you're actually dealing with
what's going on what's in your head what
your reaction to the thing is there's
another message that we got from keith
johnstone and from patricia that i've
personally found really powerful
and i use it in my teaching all the time
and that is
shoot for average and fail cheerfully
and when i tell students that especially
here at stanford these high achieving
students i can tell that they don't
really believe it they laugh they
they're sort of guarded and they're
still sort of holding themselves back
but over the course of 10 weeks of
practicing doing this of of doing it
with other people of getting the the
experience of that playful support being
able to fail and have it still work out
i start to see the armor crack
i see them kind of emerge and show up as
themselves which is something that
they've been holding back
there's so much pressure to be
outstanding and original and
and you know break the paradigm and yeah
the truth is that we can't actually get
to those spaces
if we're protecting ourselves
we need to
allow ourselves to play and discover and
be authentic i think those skills can be
learned over time you know you can as
dan said the more you do it the more you
tap into something kind of true
instead of
trying to wow everybody with this
false
version i really think this is critical
to take the time
to
understand how much pressure we put on
ourselves and how much judging we do of
ourselves that gets in the way of us
actually being able to do what it is we
want to do and that notion of
reflecting on what happens if it doesn't
go well accepting the failure really is
liberating
we are certainly not saying
that this is the only way to communicate
i all of us agree
there are situations where we need to do
what we
traditionally do prepare plan the
wording has to be right
but to have flex these other muscles and
be able to to have another approach so
we can choose in certain situations to
turn off
the evaluation and the judging and act
in another way well in patricia's book
in the opening she says you know when i
go to a surgeon i certainly want a
surgeon who is prepared and schooled up
and knows what they're doing but i also
want if something goes wrong for them to
be able to be present and improvise you
know also i would like that surgeon to
be able to talk to me about about what's
going on
i think if you get expert enough in your
material then that frees you up
to be
more connected more conversational
because you know deep down i know this
you know sometimes we'll do an exercise
where we'll have somebody tell the story
of their name just some story about
their name first name middle name last
name whatever or tell a story about what
they did this weekend and
remind them that when you're an expert
on the material you don't have to have
every word perfectly staged
if you build a comfort in your material
then you can be a little more
free-flowing and how you present it
being present-oriented is really
critical in what i'm hearing us discuss
and and i know a lot of improvisation
requires or invites that kind of present
orientation so i'd like to hear from
each of you a bit about how present
orientation
helps in spontaneous moments and also
let's include in that this notion of
listening many of us in a q a situation
where people are asking us questions or
asking for our feedback feel that in
that moment we are being challenged that
we are that we are being
evaluated and i know attacked in some
cases and i know improv has a lot to say
about this notion of offers and
opportunities do you want to make
mention of that i think that reframing
these situations as as a positive than
versus a negative can make a big
difference
yeah i mean one of the improvisers
mantras is that there are always offers
coming at us from all different
directions and that we should notice
those offers so an improviser goes on
stage with absolutely nothing planned
and just the posture of their partner
coming on stage will say ah that person
is just a little slumped or that person
is a little proud and i'll notice that
and i'll treat it as an offer and now
i'll have a sense of what we're
beginning to do on stage so there are
these offers
everywhere and our audiences for sure
are giving us offers all the time yeah
when an au in the moment when an
audience member is challenging when they
ask a question that might have an
aggressive tone to it something that
might put you on the defensive
especially if you're not that confident
about that specific area one of the
things that i learned as a facilitator i
was taught and i've seen it happen over
and over again
that person
is the most engaged that's what they're
showing you they are engaged and they
are the best opportunity it's not a
fight you're not gonna fight with them
but they're an opportunity so take that
energy get delighted whenever something
goes wrong on the improv stage
improvisers just get excited they let
they get their eyes light up and they go
oh good what can we do with this it's
live it's an opportunity it's new
information i
i am surprised that that i'm the one
that has to say this but yes and yeah
isn't that what it's all about yeah
right so someone challenging you someone
being sort of negative or or a problem
we're instantly reframing that and i've
seen it many times the person who has
the most challenging question is most
likely to be your champion they're the
one who is going to be your biggest
supporter when you work with them and
are able to engage and turn around the
other thing i learned was when they ask
a question it has a lot of energy behind
it don't answer
say tell me more or say what thoughts do
you have about that like let them keep
talking because sometimes
you're just misinterpreting that
negative energy it's just they're fired
up in another way and the other thing
this this is a story i tell in the class
that matt and i teach together there was
a time where i was pitching a tv show
and the person i pitched it to
said to me
tell me why this isn't a sci-fi story
and i
i thought this isn't a sci-fi story it
never occurred to me it has like maybe
there's some element um and and i said
why do you say that and it turned out
that that person's boss had been burned
by the last three sci-fi
stories that they had made what this
person was doing was actually asking me
for ammunition that he could then take
to his boss
to sell my story you know he was solving
a problem that i didn't even know
existed and so rather than seeing that
question as an attack see it as this
person is bringing information
from like outside of my
headspace right like i wasn't aware of
this
by bringing that question
he's bringing his concerns and he was
actually trying to help me
what i love so much about that story is
it brings together many of the things we
talked about you you had to be present
in the moment right to see that that's
what was going on you had to take the
offer that he was giving you and see it
as an offer that there was something of
value there so you really had to be
present you had to listen and have that
money and i did paraphrase i said where
i asked a question back is dan said you
know tell me more
why where is this coming from
and it turned out the deeper source was
something useful to both of us
i think for folks who are find
themselves in
situations where they're handling
objections or taking questions this
advice and guidance is critical you have
to listen you have to be open you have
to see how this is now an opportunity to
expand and extend versus to just defend
and entrench i mean one thing that was
very powerful that i learned was from
you matt which is to make this into a
conversation rather than a performance
and that mindset shift of i'm presenting
i'm in front of a group but it's much
more like i'm in a conversation where
i'm putting information out you're
giving information back i'm taking that
in and moving it forward and that's a
way to kind of demystify
or take the anxiety out of these these
situations absolutely being
conversational always i think is
beneficial
we've talked about a lot of really
interesting useful skills that people
can use to feel more comfortable
speaking in a spontaneous way i'm
curious if if both of you
would be willing to be a little
spontaneous we end each of these
podcasts no no no no no we talked about
this no not this
all right so so indulge me then i mean
yes and
yes so i'm going to ask each of you
three questions that we end each podcast
with so
we'll alternate back and forth so and
we'll switch who goes first so you so
one of you will truly be being
spontaneous so dan i'm going to start
with you
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
adam already said it earlier i just want
to pull it back in
it is not about you
nice very good adam same question to you
what five to seven words would be on
your slide title that was yours
it's not about you it's about them oh oh
okay we'll give you credit that's all
right yeah that's all right so adam
a little bit less original yeah we'll
give you the question number two but i
was present
and i shot forever and i failed
cheerfully
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
you know who i really enjoy is uh is
trevor noah the the new um i new it's
been years now um host of the daily show
and his autobiography audiobook is just
amazing but what i like about him is a
mix of he does seem always present he
seems always him
you know you really feel his voice but
he can
speak
with authority he can speak sometimes
crassly or glibly or sometimes like
really kind of profoundly um and so i
enjoy the range that he brings and yet
it's always him
so that authenticity yeah yeah and
specificity and and naturalness yeah i
really enjoy
watching him so dan who's a communicator
that you admire and why i'm gonna go a
little bit obscure here um almost
20 years ago i went to the edinburgh
fringe festival there's a british
comedian storyteller named daniel kitson
who was hosting uh there was an event
called late and live and layton live was
notorious because it was at midnight and
the crowd would be packed and it was and
you get a random collection of stand-up
comics and they were handling hecklers
just pure like that was the culture of
that environment and daniel was the host
of it
and he was so
masterful
at
playing with what people would shout out
he would disarm them so easily he was so
present
not high status not aggressive very calm
and comfortable but so comfortable in
his own skin and he would name exactly
what was there in the room that's cool
that's cool so usually the third
question that i that i ask ask the
person to give three ingredients that go
into a successful communication recipe
but i'm gonna turn this into a little
bit of an improv game so instead of each
of you telling three let's each and i'll
play as well say one ingredient that you
would put in the recipe so adam what's
what's one thing you would put in
cinnamon
no i'm sorry no i'm sorry um
uh like
how do i say this you build up a trust
in yourself over time and by by putting
yourself out there in safer ways and
then increasingly you get more and more
comfort i think i think ultimately
having some trust in yourself is is a
really powerful ingredient dan here's
something we haven't quite talked about
but it fits in everything like plan the
talk be ready have do do the research
get think about the audience and their
needs but in the moment when you're
delivering use an opportunity to pay
attention like meet people beforehand in
the room have some quick conversations
listen to the speaker right before you
and use something from the room in your
talk you don't have to change everything
you're going to do but reference
something that's come up on that day in
that moment so that your talk is
particular to that space and that it's
just insane
i like that this notion of trust
yourself be ready and i would add to
this have fun
we put a lot of pressure on ourselves
i'll never forget when i went for my
first martial arts black belt uh
somebody i trust in a mentor right
before i went to do the test he looked
at me and said have fun and i was
in total utter shock how can this be fun
this is this is something that's going
to be torturous but taking that approach
really made a big difference i think
those three ingredients would make for a
wonderful spontaneous speaker
thank you for that and thank you for
joining today i really hope that people
listening in take to heart the advice
that we gave
it's about the approach you take it's
about having that open mindset being
present listening relying on structure
trusting in yourself taken together
those are the skills that will help
somebody become a better spontaneous
speaker thank you guys thank you
you've just listened to think fast talk
smart a podcast produced by stanford's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts you can find us on
social media at stanford gsb